the jurogan experience like you've heard
the [ __ ] they're doing in la we were
talking about before the show today
that la they're gonna allow outdoor
dining but you can't have a tv on
what the [ __ ] does that mean
who are you who the [ __ ] are you to tell
people they can't have a tv on
like what do they have a jamie is there
an explanation
for why why does that matter because it
doesn't matter they're [ __ ] criminals
these [ __ ] people think they can just
tell you what to do la county says
no tvs for outdoor diners at local
restaurants
what why why yeah why
does it say why this provision is
effective until further notice
they don't have to tell you they don't
have to tell you [ __ ]
these [ __ ] creeps i mean
i mean it's like i said before it's like
at least you don't got to worry about
them
broadcasting the coronavirus sporting
events like we talked about
yeah this is what it says it says the
broadcast performing to
patrons in an effort to keep restaurants
from becoming overcrowded for sporting
events
such as the upcoming super bowl first of
all there's no evidence that this virus
spreads outside
none zero zilch is it you can't find any
evidence there's no studies
if you look at all the like when they
have a pie chart
of how the the virus spreads it spreads
in supermarkets
it spreads a little bit and you know
various indoor businesses
and you know there's a very small
percentage you show in restaurants but
it's mostly people working in the
kitchen
that are catching it you know they're in
tight quarters working together all the
time
there's no evidence that it spreads
outside none so this idea about them
being overcrowded
there's no evidence here's the thing
because
i remember uh before la shut down i
remember saddle ranch
oh yeah what was like packed and stuff
and
but it was outside but they were like
packed and i was like that looks
unhealthy too
yeah like that like didn't that like
they're outside but they're still
close together as well we couldn't do
shows right down the street
and you know why it's because they were
about to start doing shows again
but then somebody called the health
department on the comedy store and then
that [ __ ] shut it down but why
because i think it was like a troll i
think it was like a troll or somebody
who who didn't like [ __ ] with the comedy
store like that like
but that's what happened what were they
saying like what could they say they got
shut down
they just said that um all i remember is
that they said that it was a um
that it was like a health problem and
stuff like that and so they
so they shut it down right when we were
about they was gonna start letting us
perform in the parking lot
yeah i remember that bring back the best
of the comments during the parking lot
and um and yeah somebody got it shut
down
that doesn't make any sense that's
[ __ ] up so did you ever see when we
had to perform in the window
yeah i did see that yeah that [ __ ] was
that that that didn't make any sense
actually it was hard no connection no
connection with people
and i tried to beat the window so many
times i could never do it
i saw a doc i saw darnell beat the
window i was like ah he beat the window
to beat the window dino can beat
bulletproof glass
like he could be prison glasses oh he
gonna get his
ah catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience